BLACKHAWKS!
>> Keith: IT'S A PERFECTLY
EXECUTED THREE-ON-TWO,O, AND TH
PACE GOES RIGHT UP THEEX DeBRIN.
IT'S A POWER-PLAY GOALF SEIDER.
HIS SECOND OF THE O WE CAN ADMIT
KANE PASS A COUPLE MORE TIMES.T.
THE BLACKHAWKS TAKE T HIMSELF AI
IT'S WAVED OFF.
NONO
FABBRI MAKES HIM PAY.
HE DIVES INTO THE NET.E SUTER' .
KEPT ALIVE BY BERTUZZI AND
DEFLECTS OFF THE SKATE O OFFICI.
AND THERE'S THE PASS FROM
JONATHAN TOEWS RIGHT ON THE TAPE
TO D, SCORE!
DEFLECTED IN FRONT.
A HAT CONFUSED.
DID NOT MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION
AND EVENTUALLY STROM
ODD-MAN RUSH.
DeBRINCAT.
HE SCORES! FROM DeBRINCAT AND TH
SEIDER WITH A DRIVE, HE SCORES
RAYMOND PASS INTO THE
WHEELHOUSE, SEIDER LEANS INTO
ITKNOCKED DOWN BY DYLAN LARKIN.
LARKIN WITH THE SHOT.
SCORE!
>> Keith: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SHOTOT
NOW LEDDY,D GETS A GIFT AS THAT
PUCK IS GIVEZI WRAPS IT BACK AR.
LARKIN
DYLAN LARKIN TRYING TO KEEP THAT
PUCK I